[Music]
my wife's really good about like
constantly reading to the kids do you
read I try I try to read to him and he
really loves it he has a pile of books
that have trucks and cars and every
morning at 6:00 in the morning we come
down and he in his footie pajamas he
goes gay he goes baa baa and he gets his
books and that means it's time for him
to sit on my lap and I have to read the
same books
[Music]
honest to god it seemed like five books
yeah since every morning yeah every
morning and the books don't change it's
the same books they're these books right
and so basically I just sometimes try to
amuse myself by as you can see I have a
potty mouth I just start swearing so
I'll be what you swear while you're
reading to him validating what you're
doing but can you just give us a sample
of like I don't know heart of your book
yeah yeah but I don't know some choice
you have your beautiful 16 month old son
cement mixer and Digger because honestly
it's dull to finally dull yeah there's
you just I sometimes I just can't I have
to do a take to the invisible camera
right like I can't believe I'm doing yes
yeah dr. Seuss must be hard because the
you throw in those words and it ruins
the rhythm you know dr. Seuss it's dr.
Seuss dr. Seuss is great yeah I'm
talking about books about trucks yeah
and cars right there's not a story right
it's just it's just trucks and you're
losing your mind you would are you
worried at all that you swear around
your your child you're older dude does
your daughter ever pick up on this one
of your daughters well we had an
incident I would thank you okay
let's hear about that my well I was
always defending myself thinking well
they're too young they're not they don't
really get it they're not gonna and I
don't swear that much right and they're
not gonna pull it sounds like you kind
of do sounds like you're reading them a
book every day and every other word is
the f-word I know the other night my
five-year-old was in kindergarten we
were getting ready for dinner and she
was about to go leave the room to wash
her hands and she said what are we
having for dinner and I said salmon rice
and broccoli and as she turned on her
heels and left the room she said that's
the worst dinner I remember her
[Applause]
you